today we talked a lot about the visa
liberalisation visa freedom has many
advantages for both the European members
Union member states and the countries
whose citizens don't need shorts a visa
anymore but we also talked a lot about
that we should not allow that visa
freedom for holiday makers and business
travelers leads to abuse and therefore
today we decided that we need an
improved emergency brake a suspension
mechanism and we reached agreement today
on exactly such a measure the new
mechanism against abuse of visa freedom
will be much stronger than the current
system and I look forward to working
with the European Parliament to realize
this soon the successful implementation
of the eu-turkey statement is an
absolute priority the results of these
are clear as the number of arrivals to
the Greek islands continues to go down
two degrees in addition returns to
Turkey have also increased they did not
hide my disappointment with ministers
today so far only 1580 young persons in
need of international protection have
been relegated from Greece and Italy
tens of thousands of people continue to
remain stranded in Greece and the
situation on the ground will not improve
in the coming months unless we relegate
those who are intact to the location
which are the majority to those who
think there is some alternative or plant
be I want to be very clear there is not
location from Greece needs to happen and
urgently